al final de esta polvorienta pista en el
sureste de inglaterra apenas hay señales
de humedad este es el suelo desde donde
el río támesis suele emerger pero el año
más seco en décadas ha desplazado la
fuente varios kilómetros del río abajo
dejando solo tierra quemada donde antes
fluye el agua la sequía es un síntoma de
la extrema ola de calor que envuelve al
reino unido y gran parte del continente
europeo algunas zonas de inglaterra y
gales han sido puestas bajo aviso de
calor extremo con temperaturas que
podrían alcanzar los 35 grados celsius
creo que hace unos 10 años la máxima que
alcanzábamos era de unos 26 grados y
ahora es como llegar a los 30 es
demasiado para mí más al este en esta
provincia polaca la sequía también ha
dejado el río reducido y a sus orillas
expuestas se han recogido toneladas de
peces muertos en el cauce poder que es
el segundo más largo del país en lo que
se ha descrito como un desastre
ecológico
se necesitan al menos 10 años para que
el agua a los peces y toda la fauna
piscícola se recupere este es un
desastre que nunca ha ocurrido antes y
sentiremos las consecuencias durante
mucho tiempo las llamas en el noroeste
de españa ya han quemado más de 22 mil
hectáreas desde el comienzo del verano
mientras la fuerza aérea española
trabaja sin descanso para controlar los
incendios forestales que se propagan por
la región escenas similares se viven en
el vecino portugal donde más de 10 mil
hectáreas se han convertido en humo en
los últimos cinco días el equivalente al
10 por ciento de este patrimonio natural
de la unesco
miles de personas en toda europa se han
visto afectadas por incendios olas de
calor e inundaciones sólo en las últimas
semanas consecuencias terribles del
cambio climático que según expertos será
cada vez más frecuente e intenso